we want to solve a real problem it's
better if we could address a real pain
point and not just nice to have feature
if you can create a real value for your
users they will be happy to pay for it
harnessing habits leads to more revenue
it drives a higher customer lifetime
value and it gives us greater
flexibility to increase prices if you
are able to create a customer habit it
will supercharge your monetization plan
however it's a challenge first make sure
users form a habit using your app at
least once or twice a day is a good
start second and Delta Phi the four
aspects of your product triggers actions
rewards and investments in the following
videos we will see how to identify them